in this video I want to talk about the
tertiary level of Stroeve protein
structure so when we talk about tertiary
structure we're talking about sort of
the overall 3d arrangement of a
particular protein so actually note that
here overall 3d structure of a protein
so and we're specifically well not
specifically but we're definitely
including particularly on the side
chains and how they interact including
interactions between side chains okay
that's going to be very very important
when we start talking about the actual
specifics we're talking about tertiary
structure now with interest restructure
we're talking about you know the overall
3d structure now we have the overall 3d
structure of proteins we're usually
thinking about one of two things raised
of thinking about fibrous proteins or
globular proteins I want to talk about
both of them but we're mostly going to
be talking about globular proteins let
me just introduce introduce fibrous
proteins briefly so fibrous proteins
they're their polypeptide backbone again
on our EGA abbreviate it as PPT the
polypeptide backbone does not fold upon
itself
oops so the polypeptide backbone does
not fold upon itself in a fibrous
protein and when you think about that
what you think about fibrous or fiber
you probably think of like a long string
right and that's essentially what these
things are um so there are long rods
kind of these proteins long rods of
amino acids and usually they're just
mechanically strong and they're usually
structural proteins strong and
structural
and some examples of this just briefly
are things like collagen which is you
know in cartilage and keratin which is
in your like hair and nails okay so
nothing too crazy about fibrous proteins
is not too many details I want to
discuss when it comes to fibrous
proteins I'm primarily concerned lobular
proteins so globular proteins on the
flip side their polypeptide backbone
does fold upon itself so polypeptide
backbone oh we can this forgive my
writing the polypeptide backbone does
fold upon itself okay and then it ends
up becoming a compact instance fear
achill and that's probably you would
think when you're thinking about a
globular protein right if we're talking
about a globular protein if you think
about it just a glob it does a word glob
you're probably thinking of something
like a ball and that's kind of what it
is it's compact spherical more or less
not necessarily a perfect circular sort
of sphere but it's to that degree and
typically when we're talking about a
globular proteins they are typically
water soluble so they'll exist in in
hydrophilic environments typically right
that's something I wanted to mention
briefly about fibrous proteins that
they're often they are often not water
soluble so anyway though so they're
typically water soluble or or you know
soluble in polar environments polar or
hydrophilic environments for instance
sample of a hydrophilic or polar
environment would be like the blood like
in our blood for instance there are
blood proteins one of them of course
being hemoglobin which you're probably
familiar with it so actually that brings
me to this this idea these few examples
I wanted to mention hemoglobin so two
examples I'll just note here are
hemoglobin which we will talk about
later and myoglobin which is a protein
in the muscles we'll talk about both of
these in a later video but let me kind
of give you an idea about what to sort
of expect or imagine when you're
thinking about a globular protein so if
you think about a globular protein what
I want you to imagine is an orange just
you know that like the fruit and if you
have a you know a whole orange it's just
you know some sort of it's a ball shape
right
so I actually separate this up now
because I don't know I would want to
focus on the fibrous protein right now
we're just talking about globular
proteins so with these globular proteins
imagine an orange and imagine you take a
slice of that orange so if we take a
slice of that orange let's actually draw
this in orange since we're talking about
the color orange if we have we take a
slice of the orange like this right what
do we see you'll see like the top of the
fruity portion on the inside here right
and it's separated kind of by this this
like skin right of the of the orange
right this outer layer here right it
kind of makes up the skin of the orange
and then the inside portion is the fruit
just for the sake of this diagram and it
color it in yellow alright so this this
portion here is going to make it in
yellow right you would have like actual
slices of the orange in the edible
portion inside okay so we just imagine
that let's just imagine this being a
protein right if we were to put if we
took a protein took a slice of it this
could be could be kind of what it looks
like these outer portions right if we're
talking about a globular protein and
it's going to be in a in a hydrophilic
environment right if we
water molecules all around here or some
sort of polar substance outside you have
to keep in mind that this globular
protein right is made up of a really
long chain of amino acids or multiple
polypeptide chains in any case if we
have that there are some that are
nonpolar so that are polar and the
reason why we talked about that and
mentioned it specifically is that we
know that like dissolves like so if we
see that there are amino acids on this
outside portion here and this is there
in a in a hydrophilic environment we
would expect site or the side chains of
the amino acids that are polar to be on
the outside here right we wouldn't
because we want polar groups to interact
with the polar environment right so what
I want to jot down here is that we
expect that portion to be a hydrophilic
portion right because it's dissolved in
the water
oops not hydrophobic so you can
hydrophilic portion right that'll
contain a polar amino acids right
because we want those um we want those
polar side chains interacting with the
polar water out here so what's going to
be buried on the inside here well just
the opposite right if it's the
hydrophobic portion of the protein we
would expect that it contains nonpolar
side chains or nonpolar amino acids so
hopefully you can kind of see or imagine
that if you have a protein then if it's
in a water soluble environment or a
hydrophilic environment then anything on
the outside surface it's going to be
interacting with the water probably
contains and should contain polar amino
acids so examples of those things right
if you remember things like serine right
or or I don't know what else there's
threonine or
glutamine etc right whereas these
hydrophobic ones and might be things
like like alanine or or phenylalanine or
or Massiah mean who knows right just as
long as it's a nonpolar amino acid right
so this is kind of I want you to imagine
we think about these globular proteins
okay um so what actually do we think
about when we think about the 3d
structure and the folding of the
globular proteins so let's actually
begin to talk about that okay so let's
talk about the folding of globular
proteins right because we talked about
we mentioned over here just a moment ago
that the polypeptide backbone actually
does fold upon itself so once it folds
upon itself there's got to be something
that holds it in that folded form right
what would do that well there are a
bunch of different things that we're
going to talk about here okay so folding
the proteins that make up the third the
tertiary structure so um there are of
course um there what is something that's
specifically something simple that holds
them together it's just the hydrophobic
effect or hydrophobic interactions okay
and this is just the whole idea that
that if we have hydrophobic compounds
right they're going to stay away from
the water so hydrophobic compounds or
portions I should say hydrophobic
portions stay away away from water right
so that's what we see here is that these
hydrophobic portions sort of bury
themselves on the inside of the protein
right not interacting outside with the
with the polar environment right and
then um so hydrophobic residues right of
the amino acid so the hydrophobic amino
acid residues is just another sort of
way that's who described it I mean Oh
acid when it's part of a polypeptide
chain hydrophobic residues are buried on
the inside of the protein or inside of
the
okay so that's the idea behind the Hydra
of hydrophobic effect so that's what
that's going to do is allow the
hydrophobic portion to sort of interact
stay together and they're going to
actually be held together by Vander
Waals forces just London dispersion
forces if you remember that back to
general chemistry they kind of interact
hydrophobic again like dissolves like
the hydrophobic portion in Roger phobic
portions hydrophilic will interact with
hydrophilic portion so that's something
that helps maintain a protein structure
so let's talk about something else
obviously we're going to talk about
hydrogen bonds H bonds right so we
mentioned H bonds right being important
in secondary structure what makes these
hydrogen bonds different well these
hydrogen bonds that we're talking about
now are not between the backbone these
hydrogen bonds are specifically between
the R groups or the side chains okay
specifically the polar ones right and
which ones are some of those examples so
some examples are of things like serine
or threonine or tyrosine right they all
have Oh H groups right
they all have in their side chain right
they have some sort of Oh H group that
Oh H group can be involved in a hydrogen
bond between side chains right so
hydrogen bonding it's a non covalent
interaction that helps you know maintain
the integrity of that the protein once
it's folded right so if there are
hydrogen bonds there you know it means
these amino acids out here there might
be hydrogen bonds holding those together
so um yeah let's essentially the idea
behind these H bonds and how they are
different from the secondary structure
which just involves the hydrogen bonds
between the backbone now the hydrogen
bonds that were concerned with are the
art groups or between the R groups okay
the third thing I want to mention is
electrostatic interactions
static interactions electrostatic
interactions now this what am I talking
about when I mentioned electrostatic
interactions I'm talking about really
just the fact that there are some polar
groups that are charged so charged polar
side chains or groups will attract or
repel each other right based on their
charge okay so we know that opposite
charges attract and positive or
something opposite charges attract and
like charges repel so if you have an
example right let's think about if we
have two aspartate near each other okay
once this uh let's say once this protein
is like we have a protein that's all
kinds of folded right together and then
sudden let's say we have like maybe the
fifth amino acid and the 147th amino
acid happened to be next to each other
and there once the protein is folded and
they both happen to be aspartate so
let's say at a pH of seven these two
aspartate these are acidic amino acids
Part A is an acidic amino acid and it's
our group will have a negative charge
right so if we have these two negative
charges together or near each other
right what are they going to do right
those two negative charges will repel
right so that will have an effect on the
overall 3d structure of the protein
those two those two charges are going to
repel slightly maybe bend the protein in
a certain way and that can have an
effect on its overall 3d structure
another example right is if we have an
aspartate and maybe a lysine near each
other I didn't put each here near each
other near each other running out of
space here aspartate and lysine near
each other so a sparked a again has a
negative charge right lysine is one of
the basic amino acids it's going to have
a positive charge so those two residues
if they
happen to be next to each other they
will attract right and they'll come
closer so this is the whole idea behind
that if we have these amino acids that
are acidic and basic they're going to be
charged and if they're charged that can
have an effect on the the overall
structure of the amino acid
okay one more interaction I want to talk
about this fourth one here is is
disulfide bridges disulfide bridges some
of you probably already know where I'm
going with this here disulfide bridges
I'm talking about disulfide bridges I'm
thinking about cystines the amino acid
cysteine so cysteines
that are close together right if they're
close together they can form disulfide
bonds or disulfide bridges okay so so
what's going on there essentially if you
remember the side chain of abscissa teen
it kind of has it is a ch2 and then the
SH right this little file here that has
an SH right with the carbon chain over
there right so if we have two cysteines
that happen to be next to each other
oops let me mess that up if we have two
cysteines right that happen to be close
together right let me actually move this
down just a tad if we have two cysteines
next to each other and we want they can
come together and actually form they can
come together and form a bond an actual
bond between the two and come together
and form like this so this what happens
here is we've created a covalent bond
now that's imperative okay
and kind of crazy because that a
covalent bond is very very strong and I
can have you know make up the world of a
difference as far as a protein structure
so how would this actually happen well
we're losing these hydrogen's here
and so that would occur in an oxidizing
environment right if there's an
oxidizing environment we're going to get
rid of these these hydrogen's here and
create this covalent bond on the flip
side if there is a something that can
break up this this covalent bond right
going back this way that would that
would have to be caused by a reductive
environment adding those ages right so
reducing environment would break up that
bond okay so a few more things I want to
kind of highlight just very quickly here
so let me slide this over a bit things I
want to mention about these these all
these interactions here is that when
we're talking about we're talking about
these first three here we're talking
about non covalent interactions right in
none of those situations do we have do
we have an actual formation of a bond
there all the H bonds are called bonds
but they really are just non covalent
interactions right this here is called
the disulfide bridges they're actually
covalent right we're creating or
breaking a covalent bond right so I kind
of want to note briefly how how all
these different interactions can be
messed up okay so talk about Holliday
they can form and how they hold it up a
protein together what can mess these
interactions up well when we're talking
about disulfide bridges we just
mentioned that an oxidizing environment
forms them well then a reducing agent
can destroy them so these are destroyed
or disrupted if we disrupt it it's a
better sort of term in my opinion oops
these are disrupted by a reducing or
reductive environment
okay so they're formed via an oxidation
and they're broken up the error
reduction okay a hydrophobic effect that
can be disrupted by detergents so
detergents will get in there and sort of
ruin hydrophobic interactions hydrogen
bonds if you recall that's what hold
water together right if you heat up
water eventually the water molecules
separate and boil out right so hydrogen
bonds can actually be disrupted by heat
by the addition of heat
okay so electrostatic interactions right
these things can be the recharged or
uncharged right if you remember our
sparked eight right can either as a
being an acidic group it has a carboxyl
group that carboxyl group can be
protonated in which it has no charge or
deprotonated which has a negative charge
so if we alter the pH in such a way so
as to make it so that some groups are
protonated and other groups are not
maybe two groups that were initially
repelling right if we change the pH
slightly one might be you know one might
go from being charged to uncharged and
that could have an effect on you know on
them either repelling or attracting so
these an electrostatic interactions can
be disrupted by pH changes okay so all
these different things all these purple
things things I've written in purple are
sort of they describe denaturation
right denaturation is essentially just
like ruining um protein structure that's
like the sort of ruining protein
structure so um if you want to denature
a protein you're disrupting its overall
structure now we talked about again
before about how structure has all
everything to do with functions so for
altering the structure of a protein
denaturing it we're probably altering
its function and ruining it
function so this sort of wraps up you
know tertiary structure specifically
that of that describing globular
proteins in the future videos we'll talk
about these examples that were mentioned
hemoglobin myoglobin and actually fetal
hemoglobin as well so I hope that was
helpful and see next in the next video